if you want to support this channel and
get cool anime merch at the same time
like the dragon sin of Wrath Mele Otis
feel the wrath of my dragon and the lion
sin of pride esken or praise the Sun
check out our online store link in the
description what is up everybody its
Anna Mac here for anime uproar and in
this video we will be talking about who
is the strongest member of the seven
deadly sins thank you guys again for the
massive support you've shown for our
previous seven deadly sins videos I have
now created a playlist where you can
find them all in one place and I will
link that playlist in the description
one of the biggest topics of discussion
in the comments on these videos was the
question of which of the seven deadly
sins is the strongest so in this video
we will look at the facts the stats and
the unique abilities of each member in
order to rank them by power all the way
up to the strongest in order to make
sure that I'm doing the best possible
job ranking them I invited a good friend
of mine to help me with this video
yellow thank you so much for having me
man and I hope everyone watching enjoys
this video I have literally trained my
entire life for this moment
thanks so much for joining me Briggs
with a big topic like this two heads are
always better than one over at all day
Anna Mae Briggs has been making seven
deadly sins content and researching the
series for years so it is great to have
him on board for this one be sure to
check out his channel link in the
description if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins content on this channel be
sure to leave a like to let me know and
if you are new don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification valve we are
now posting daily anime content on
Twitter and Instagram so feel free to
follow us there at anime uproar before
we get started with the rankings I want
to stress that regardless of the
rankings none of these characters are
weak in fact all members of the seven
deadly sins are among the strongest
characters in the entire story and
depending on the circumstances and on
their unique skills and abilities they
can often surprise opponents
have an even higher power level than
they do also once we get to the top
three strongest members you will see
that a valid argument can be made for
all three of them potentially being the
strongest this is not an exact science
and we will do our best to explain our
logic but also provide the possible
counter arguments and of course if you
disagree with this order feel free to
tell us why down in the comments no hard
feelings
there will be some manga spoilers in
this video about the background and
abilities of the characters since there
is no other way to make this video
properly however we will not spoil what
actually happens in the story just the
powers and abilities of the characters
and starting things off with go thir
goal thir is actually a doll who was
created by a powerful mage and as a
result go Thurs body is highly resistant
to physical attacks Golder can take the
type of damage that would kill a normal
person even if his head is removed from
his body
he can simply put it back on Golder has
the unique ability known as invasion
which allows him to read the minds of
others and if he wants to he can trap
his opponents inside their own traumatic
memories Golder also has the ability to
transform parts of his body like
changing the length and color of his
hair the name of his sacred treasure is
Herot and it allows him to summon two
bows of light that he can fire at
opponents when used together with his
ability invasion the bows allow Golder
to knock a large group of people
unconscious in an instant and he can
even rewrite the memories of a large
number of people at long range due to
the fact that he is a doll goal third
doesn't need to eat or drink however he
does need his glasses because he has
very poor vision and cannot see without
them so that is a potential weakness in
battle dn is a member of the giant clan
and the Giants are known for being some
of the strongest warriors in history and
for having incredible physical strength
as such
DeeAnn is thirty feet tall and she has
outstanding physical strength and
stamina she can sustain a lot of damage
and still keep fighting and she is
especially effective in defense as
giant she has a unique ability known as
creation that enables her to manipulate
the earth in order to create massive
weapons and even moving creatures like
powerful golems that she could use in
battle against her enemies using the
dancing technique of the Giants she can
avoid attacks more effectively than the
average fighter her sacred treasure is
Gideon a massive Warhammer that enhances
her physical might and earth
manipulating abilities her overall power
level at its highest recorded level so
far in the series with 48,000 now we can
say that she is considerably stronger
than Goethe her because she was able to
defeat him in her human form after Gotha
altered the memories of Julia and her
brothers Ile during the Albion R and
it's worth noting that the Janna is much
stronger when she's at her full size ya
know cause of physics and stuff next up
is bond bond was once human but he is
now immortal because he drank from the
Fountain of Youth
this means that he doesn't age and his
body regenerates instantly whenever he
is injured that in itself is an
incredible ability to have in battle but
on top of that bond is also very fast
and strong his special ability snatch
enables him to steal objects from others
without making direct contact including
their vital organs which can obviously
be extremely deadly bond can also steal
the physical power stamina and speed of
his opponents which makes his opponent
progressively weaker as bond becomes
stronger the reason we placed bond ahead
of the end is the fact that Diane cannot
kill him due to his immortality and also
because of the nature of snatch Diane's
biggest asset is her physical strength
and using snatch bond would be able to
steal her physical strength and make
himself stronger while she gets weaker
while this process takes time because
Diane cannot kill bond due to his
immortality we believe that in a
one-on-one battle he would have plenty
of time to steal enough of her power to
win in the long run bond sacred treasure
is known as curry juice but bond
currently does not have it in his
possession however for the purposes of
this video we are assuming
that bond would be fighting at full
power with his sacred treasure by his
side and then we have King as a fairy
king can fly and he could also transform
his appearance like other fairies King
is very weak physically what he makes up
for it with his speed and immense
magical power as the fairy king he has a
special ability called disaster which
allows him to control and modify organic
matter including nature Kings sacred
treasure is the spirit sphere chassis
full which was made from the sacred tree
located inside the fairy realm the
treasure can change into different
objects and various deadly weapons like
a truckload of Spears for example and
Kings ability disaster which has power
over nature allows it to bring out the
full potential of his sacred treasure
this makes King an exceptionally
powerful character overall his ability
to fly gives him a big edge over the
other sins like Deana and bond since he
could throw deadly Spears at them from
far up in the sky and since bonds
ability snatch works only on his
opponents physical abilities bond would
not be able to counter Kings magical
attacks and the boost in power that bond
would get from taking Kings physical
strength will be very very small
even though bond is immortal king can
use his fears or other weapons to pin
bond down and trap them effectively
taking him out of commission which is
why King place is higher than bond
Deanna and Gotha in our rankings and now
on to the top three as I mentioned
earlier a valid argument can be made for
all three being the strongest depending
on the circumstances we will talk about
the details as we go but first at number
three we have Merlin Merlin is Britannia
greatest mage and she has unmatched
magical powers she is able to perform a
wide variety of useful and powerful
spells and one of her special abilities
is infinity which enables her to make
her spells last forever
Merlin even used a spell to stop her own
body from aging at age 30
making her virtually immortal and in the
world of the seven deadly sins her
magical abilities are considered to be
in a totally different league from the
powers of an ordinary mage
Merlin can levitate teleport and she
also has the ability known as absolute
cancel which allows her to cancel out
and erase the spell
of others Merlin can use her magic to
locate a specific person or object in an
area the size of an entire city and the
name of her sacred treasure is the
Morningstar of Alden the full magical
properties of this treasure are still
unknown but we know that Merlin can use
it to look in on what's happening in
other places and also to cast spells
Merlin's actual power level is
impossible to guess because of her
uncharted magical abilities we know that
she received secret knowledge-- from
both the demon king the ruler of the
demon clan and the supreme deity the
ruler of the goddess clan so it is safe
to assume that Merlin has many magical
tricks up her sleeve that no one else
even knows about because Merlin is
highly intelligent and has incredible
magical powers including secret
knowledge that no one else even knows
about we could definitely make a valid
argument that Merlin is the strongest
sin because depending on the
circumstances she could use her
intelligence and secret magical
abilities to trick and outsmart her
opponents if she uses a powerful spell
that her opponents never heard of and
she catches them off guard she could
theoretically defeat even the strongest
enemy so keeping all of this in mind on
this list we are putting her at number
three because at number two we have s
Kannur and now the moment you guys have
all been waiting for obviously the best
character in the series Aska nor praise
the [ __ ] Sun or praise the Sun if we
want to keep this PG even though at
nighttime he is confirmed to be the
weakest of the seven deadly sins as the
Sun rises each day as canora's power
grows immensely every hour until it
reaches its maximum strength at noon as
his power grows his body becomes
incredibly tall and muscular until he
reaches his peak at noon at which point
he towers over regular people both in
terms of stature and power at noon each
day s key Norse power is at its highest
for one minute and according to Merlin
herself askin or is easily the strongest
of all the seven deadly sins at this
point with a power level of over 100
in the name of acid or sacred treasure
is the divine axe Rita a massive and
insanely heavy battle axe in his daytime
form Aska door gives off an immense
amount of heat which can actually hurt
those around him but his sacred treasure
allows him to gather and store all of
that excess energy into the axe and then
release it later when he needs it now
due to the wild fluctuations of his
power between day and night it is
virtually impossible to measure the true
extent of esque North power and I
strongly believe that during that one
minute just like Merlin says that he is
the strongest sin and even potentially
the strongest in the series the problem
is I can't give him that number one spot
because he has too many weaknesses for
example during that minute if his
opponent is simply able to avoid him
which isn't unrealistic considering so
many people could fly in the series s
Cadore will start getting weaker and
weaker as time goes on and because of
this limitation Eskin or is that number
2 on the list and at number 1 we have
Mellie Otis as the son of the demon king
and a former leader of the ten
commandments meliodas says unbelievably
strong demonic powers and it is no
wonder that he is the captain of the
seven deadly sins
Mellie Otis possesses an ability known
as hell blaze which allows him to create
and manipulate mysterious black flames
this demonic ability is so powerful that
it can even injure immortal creatures
and stop them from regenerating
so even bond who is immortal can be
permanently injured by Mellie Otis when
he loses control and his demonic power
takes over Mellie Otis's power level
flies off the charts and he is able to
destroy entire kingdoms on his own but
the drawback is that in this so-called
assault mode he essentially goes berserk
which often leads to terrible collateral
damage
Mellie Otis can use full counter which
is the ability to literally counter a
magical attack and reflected back at his
opponent with even greater power than
the original attack and the more
powerful the opponent's magic the more
effective full counter is this is an
incredibly useful skill to have when
facing someone who focuses on magical
powers like King Golder and Merlin but
it cannot be used
counter physical attacks the name of
melioidosis sacred treasure is the demon
sword lost vein and it enables meliodas
to create clones of himself he can
actually create up to four clones but
the clones will be significantly weaker
than the original for much of the series
we have no idea of the true extent of
melioidosis power because the majority
of his power was sealed away by Merlin
in order to keep him from losing control
and going berserk as the story goes on
we begin to understand the true extent
of melioidosis power including the fact
that he was cursed by the demon king so
that he cannot die meaning that meliodas
is essentially immortal after unlocking
the full potential of his demonic powers
and while in his assault mode
melioidosis power level has been
measured to be as high as 140 mm and
although s kannur is still a match for
meliodas
at the height of his power at noon in
the long term le ODIs after unlocking
his full demonic powers is the strongest
sin in our opinion and that is it for
this video guys thank you for watching
and let us know down in the comments if
you agree with our rankings and if you
don't that's totally cool just let us
know why down in the comments as I said
this is not an exact science and given
the right circumstances any one of these
characters could surprise us if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
seven deadly sins content on this
channel be sure to leave a like to let
me know if you are new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and we are now posting
daily anime content on Twitter and
Instagram be sure to follow us there at
anime uproar a huge thank you to my boy
Briggs from all-day anime for helping
out with this video
always a pleasure working with him be
sure to check out his channel lake in
the description as always thank you so
much for watching thanks for all the
kind words and support a lot more seven
deadly sins content is on the way and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]